[Applause]
[Music]
the great game for me today the best
match together with the Netherlands and I think we
are good in the final we are in the
final Today Arabia is not slapped on
time and this team  He realized that he
could get there and he did and now we have to
wait and see what happens, there's no other choice
but we have to dream because this
is once every four years and
you don't give yourself much of a chance. So now
you have to enjoy it, it comes out the way it comes out, you have
toenjoy it
Inside I hope that in my staff there is
more captain than ever, as Doñano says, more
bad but I think that there is no need to
compare because each one is their own
players and people and the truth is that
I am very happy for everything for everything The
truth is a joy  despite all the
turmoil we have but at least
as they said that we have a little bit of
joy
[Applause] very
excited I swear it was the best
game I've played so far like
all the games the network suffered as
always and  we're used to But
hey we're at the end once again
once again to the final
[Applause]
[Music]
of the world it's crazy crazy
we started off on the wrong foot but
now We're at the end of the world
crazy a  Madness cannot be explained
with anything, only if I can explain it
with him, love
does not matter who wins, it does not matter who
wins, I have five grandchildren and they are here
too and they always wanted to play with
him.
picking out